KYIVE DER
THISOOTYF .
MOSCOW CLAIMS TO HAVE
EAAN FORCES
DFIGHTEAYAN
AM B1:00 LOCAL TIMHREE INN T LON
S OF HUMAN
T IIS  HE GNIFIC.
ROTELY TINLY DID ATE
DESTEV
CONTINUETH
KHARK S AT
WE 1IL
ATTA
FACIL AN ST D
HANSD ATTAS N
UKRA FOR  THE
RU S HADWNN  CARRYING HUMANITAR.
TED THE U.IS SENDING ADDITED
HEPTAN
RUIA
UKRAINE.PREPARFFN EASTERN
DE UP HABENCS OFLL
EARLY AND OFTEN.ORNOLE
RSUSSIAN FG A RTGS TO .GHTERS BA
HORORS WHERE SAF COMFORT. PEOPLT
TEMPORARY E SPWL.D  TO KEEP
THEIR 7-RA
XISHARHEC
DI
MOST O
HEELNO WATER, NO GAS
EVERYTHINGFROM THE
>> FORMPEXAMPLATTERED.
>> Reporter: TAMARA TUTORS , TIS
BEEN HERE MOHANT OF PELEVE B
WIH THEYAV MONEYO GO
NLL HE SAOLDOVE AB
ILTER SSRIKE.
MAN, CNN, EASTERN
INEVERYDAY
OVERALNTER
MA BLEVELSE SITEHAVEUKRAINIAN O
NOW ABNORMAL HIGH.
IN PARTICULAR, IHE FSQUARE
MILELUE
ANMAINED HIGFO
FOSTHE REAATED ITHSOS  RED
NTRAL UTE,S  OTH IN
HIT BY EASP.E WORLD KITCHEN CEF
ATTACK LESS THAN4 WAS
STANDING RIGER PP R WCAM
STAFF.
NOT TOO LONG AMI SEE, TREMENDOU
RIN BACK.A LOT
AF WOUND HOSPITA
D IN THE NTBUD ONE  WHIS
ST
OV A O A
AROUNDECES ON
JUOUS AMOUNT O
IND FOR NO